Turkey is Hamas. Turkey is Hamas. Guys, is this working on you
again? Turkey is Hamas. Turkey is Hamas. Turkey is Hamas. Turkey
is Hamas. >> You might say his platform is pro war crime.
He's the war crime guy. That's >> That's crazy. >> Who
I think whoever blew up the school must have meant to do it.
[laughter]
>> It's so transparent what Ethan's saying there, right?
That guy is getting a state funeral. Yeah, we're [__]
It's like a thousand-year BB Reich at this point. Okay.
Oh, wait. Is the loner box thing good? Maybe the loner box thing
is good. Okay, let's do the loner box thing first. We'll do this
first. >> Speaking of Scottish, loner box is a is a is
a Scott and it
>> certainly am. You were talking about >> Um, Loner
Box. Do you go by Loner Box? Mr. Box. >> Yeah, Loner Box.
Box. >> I know your first name, but I don't know if it's
public. >> Um, [snorts] I mean, it's public because of the
doctors. You can call me Naz if you want. It's easier. >> That's
his first name. >> More personal. >> Um, so I mean,
you've been following what's going on in Iran pretty closely.
I kind of [snorts] just want to do a brief here for our audience
to catch up because we've been we've been talking about it a
bit here and we'll talk to Marty. Um
there's a lot of different like what I'm seeing
on my feed and the people I know. I do I do think it's tough.
It is tough that you are feeling like you know you got docked
because your first name was revealed or sorry not your first
name your your full name was revealed.
I think there's a little bit more than that. Maybe there's more
than
And then you hang out with Dan. Okay. I yeah is a lot of like
the Persians here in America are they're joyous. I think they
also can be equally concerned and worried about how things go
from here. But I see [snorts] people who are happy that this
government is, you know, being beheaded as they say, >> right?
[snorts] >> But then online you see people like Hassan
and left it. They're the ones who swear this is a terrible thing,
a desecration. I mean there's other things like Trump is over.
This is definitely >> I haven't watched Hassan's coverage.
What is I don't know what Hassan's opinions are on this. I feel
like I'm I I know he doesn't like the strikes.
I can't imagine he's defending like the Iranian regime overall.
Although maybe maybe he'd defend the Iranian regime.
Um he does he does tend to like sort of stand by anybody who's
trying to shut down the genocide in Israel. I can't imagine it
though because like just because of the crackdowns on protesters,
right? Like that's got to be that's got to be something you just
cannot conscient if you're Hassan, right? He isn't defended overall.
Yeah, I maybe I'd have to see his takes because I do feel like
a lot of people are just super lazy and they're like everybody
just loves the Ayatollah all of a sudden. It's like no, nobody
likes the Ayatollah. Pretty much everybody universally condemns
the Ayatollah.
Nobody liked him. Nobody was like sad when he died. Nobody outside
of Iran, right? We just we didn't care. That's not what this
is illegal, right? [laughter] That's a whole other thing conversation.
just in
>> he's been very snarky towards Persian
From what I can tell, it seems like the Persian diaspora sort
of deserved the Stark. Unless the miracle happens. If the miracle
happens, then maybe not. Okay? And trust me, if the miracle happens,
I would support it. If there's like a massive group there with
weapons and organization and they're going to take over the country
like right away, I would support that.
I'd be happy for that. I just don't see any evidence of it. I
see no I I in fact only see evidence of the contation about what's
happening and how people [snorts] are reacting to it. It seems
that if you ask the vast majority of Iranians there and abroad
they would they would be happy with the current outcome. Do I
have that right box in your estimate? >> Hassan responds
to Iran the Iranian diaspora celebrating their own country being
bombed as hundreds of Iranians are now dead from US air strikes.
I can't go oh I did see some of this. I did see
>> like I am a diasporoid.
Okay. I am a diasporoid myself and I cannot and I can't go back
to Turkey. Turkey has no free speech. Turkey is very heavy in
its prosecution and persecution of people who have spoken out
against the state. I've written extensively back in the day at
Hington Post about the Turkish coupata. Okay? And I was critical
of the government regardless. Right? I was critical of the government
and I still am and I haven't stopped being critical of the Ardan
regime. However, there has never been a moment in my life where
I have felt the indignity in my soul of >> Oh, I've not
seen this, Lucas. I would love to see this actually. The Iran
cost ticker site. Yes. Like every I'm sorry. And it is. Listen,
that could be, you know, pro-ranian regime propaganda,
but unfortunately that is just the facts for Americans. If you're
America first, if that's your if that's your described or you
know preferred ethos, you're America first,
then that site should concern you, right? Saying Turkey would
be better off uh with with an American puppet installed in its
leadership. It is the most undignified,
disgusting
wormlike behavior that I have ever seen. and for some weird
>> I mean I don't I don't even disagree that that could
be the case for Iran that they would be better off with a an
American puppet or something like that's not even necessarily
not the case. It's that
again I'll I'll keep reiterating this
if there is no plan for how to transition that government out.
If this was not about regime change but you use the Iranian like
the plight of the Iranian people currently under this regime
as a pretext then you are a disgusting person. You are a disgusting
lying piece of [__]
Okay, which I as far as I can tell is nearly every Republican
so far. Reason there are so many so many in the Iranian diaspora,
so many in the Cuban diaspora, so many in the Venezuelan diaspora
that straight up think that this is the appropriate measure.
It is disgusting to me. It's heinous. It's heinous behavior.
I'm telling you, my uncle died. I couldn't go back to my country
that I grew up in to see his funeral. And if you think in spite
of all of that, when Israel comes out and says Turkeykey's next,
if you think I'm not going to say that, no matter how much I
hate Ardan, if you think I'm not going to sit there and say,
"Oh yeah, it would be much better if I could just go back to
Turkey, see my family." uh when Israel
>> I think there's a big difference here in that as much
as as much as Turkey I'm sure cracks down on pro on protesters
or descent I got to imagine in Turkey
like at least there's vestigages of descent right it's not like
a religious thing there's got to be like vestigages it can't
be like it can't be anywhere near on the Iranian level right
Turkeyy's too much of like a a first world country at this point
to really punch that I think it's got to be it's got to be like
lower key I have no doubt that they'll jail dissident, but they
have to be like incredibly loud, incredibly disruptive dissident,
right? I would imagine that is disgusting.
That is the most wormlike
behavior that anyone could ever engage in. It's disgusting to
me. It's heartless. It's disgusting. It already happened in Turkey,
too. Fetakulan is an American CIA asset, okay? And they were
able to develop a parallel state in Turkey. They took over the
courts. They took over the police. They took over the military
and they tried to do a coup d'etat and it was very bloody. Turkish
people died. They took over Turkish fighter jets and they bombed
Turkish soil killing Turkish civilians. Those jets got refueled
by Americans.
Those jets took off from American military bases. Have you no
dignity? Have you no soul? How can you see your countrymen, your
country women die directed by the American state and then think
this is somehow going to lead to a a positive result? Insanity.
It is dis
that is dude. It's actually going to be crazy the kind of scops
we're going to have to watch play it with Turkey. I wonder what
the plan is for Turkey cuz that's the next that's like the next
thing that Israel is going up against. Like the level I don't
but like it's a NATO ally. It's in NATO. How do you how do you
[__] with Turkey?
How do you do it? I don't know how you do it. Disgusting. Maybe
that's the reason why I'm so rough on the diaspora populations
in the United States of America that beg for the >> Nelli
Bennett just did a speech about Turkey. Dude, >> it disgusts
me. Okay, there are so many Turkish people that [__]
despise me for recognizing the Armenian genocide, for saying
that like uh you know uh uh Kurds deserve uh their own state.
They're
um it could be it could be the Kurd stuff, right?
Like America's got relationships, not necessarily good relationships
with the Kurds, very very off and on. Okay, America is very hot
and cold with the Kurds. Okay, you're our allies. Oh, wait. We
don't even know you. Oh, no. You're our allies again. Oh, we
don't. Who the [__] are you? No, you're our allies
again. Okay. America very hot and cold with Kurds. >> Statesless.
In spite of all that, in spite of all the [__] that
I eat from Turkish nationalists, from Turkish Well, Turkish Islamists
don't actually hate me as much anymore because of my advocacy
for the Palestinian cause, but from the >> Well, I but
I thought that I thought the Americans were with the Kurds again
in Syria, weren't they? They abandoned them in Afghanistan, right?
But didn't they didn't they work with like and obviously they'd
probably be different groups. They're like different geographic
locations, but I I think in Syria they worked with the Kurds
again. >> Turkish nationalists from Turkish liberals in
spite of all >> and that's like um if you look into it
that's like a big that's probably why Turkey did so much work
to back a coup in Syria because the Kurds in Syria were working
against are working against Turkish interests and will all the
time. They would. It's how the the Kurds in Turkey basically
like organize and launch attacks on Turkey or with Turkey is
the Kurd they they're sort of blended. They go back and forth
over the border with Syri the Syrian Kurds. Like those two groups
work together a lot. I think Erdogan's got peace with them. I
watched a video on it not long ago. I think they're mostly like
fine now. They're kind of in like a ceasefire, >> Oh, that
you will never see me defend intervention in Turkey. You will
never see me defend intervention in the hands of America and
Israel. And [laughter]
they also abandoned them in Syria. Just last month, they gave
them up to the Aljelani government. Rajaba appelled to the government.
Update. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So, poor Kurds. Can we just get
a Kurdistan somewhere, guys? This is actually up. These people
get everywhere, man. There's I I swear every time I hear about
the Kurdish people, they're like they're like trying to get their
together and then somebody like them over again. Every single
I've never heard a story about how like the Kurds trusted somebody
and then it all worked out. They're like, [laughter]
if you were anti-Semitic, hypothetically, you might say they're
like the mirror image of the Jewish people. Okay. Every single
time the Kurds trust somebody, they get over. Every time somebody
trusts I dis I disavow my own joke. Okay, that joke was horrible.
Do not laugh at that. That was a terrible joke. Do not do not
in Turkey. I will always stand against that. It is disgusting.
It It blows my goddamn mind that people sit there and celebrate
the children are being slaughtered and they sit there and they
celebrate it. It's nasty. >> Okay. Israel's former PM Natali
Bennett a few days ago, Turkey is the new Iran. They're not going
to stop at Thran. Israel is a threat to the entire Middle >> A
new Turkish threat is emerging. I want to be very clear. Turkey
and Qatar have gained influence in Syria, are seeking influence
elsewhere and everywhere throughout the region. And from here,
I warn
Turkey is the new Iran. >> Bro, you didn't even get rid
of Iran
>> Iran not even gone yet, bro. >> Erdogan is sophisticated,
dangerous,
and he seeks to encircle Israel. And while some senior Israelis
were on Qatar's payroll,
Qatar and Turkey are nourishing
the Islamic Brotherhood monster
that is growing. And >> dude,
this is why Erdogan was very hesitant to just disow Hamas and
just be like, "Hamas is evil and Hamas and I totally sanction
everything cuz every leader in the region knows that they're
next, that they might be next every single time.
Every single time. Every other every other
player knows.
So again, this won't stop." So So hold on, hold on. Somebody
said Turkeykey's second largest army in NATO. So, while I understand
that, if you think Israel is looking to directly engage Turkey
militarily, you would be crazy. They're obviously not going to
do that. But what I think they will do is notice that where is
Turkey vulnerable? Well, economically, they're not a part of
very many like um like I I think they're they're possibly in
some sort of economic agreement with the EU, but they're not
in the EU itself.
They might be economically vulnerable. Okay.
And I'm guessing that when you start painting them as a bastion
of terrorism, that's to start to look for sanctions probably,
right?
uh might become as dangerous as the one created by Iran.
Turkey and Qatar are gaining influence not only in Syria but
also in Gaza
through the front door
and everywhere and trying to create a new choke rink. Uh Turkey
is trying to flip Saudi Arabia against us and establish a hostile
Sunni access with nuclear Pakistan.
>> Yeah, I think all of these people
I think all of these people have watched your foreign policy
with the US like unfold in that region and I'm I'm guessing all
the Sunnis are like, you know what? Uh
we probably got something got to be done. Something got to be
done over here because holy right. I would I would imagine a
lot of them are like
this. It's not good. Don't they have nukes? If so, Turkey I don't
know if Turkey has nukes. You just said Pakistan has nukes. I
know that. Yeah. I don't know if Turkey doesn't have nukes. Turkey
has somebody just said Turkey has US nukes like US missile silos
in it
which would be interesting.
So I think the I think the thing with Turkey here would be looking
for economic sanctions. I think that's what they're they're going
to look to isolate Turkey economically which is going to degrade
their capacity to do anything right. And that is the threat Turkey
presents as far as I know is Turkey's economy is actually set
up in a very good place. They've got the the access to Russia
and like the wider part of Asia with sorry like northern Asia
you know Russia and all of this. They've got access to all of
that through the Black Sea and they can trade through um Istanbul,
right? Constantinople as as us whites call it. So they can they
can go through the Bosphorus and and trade into the wider Mediterranean
as well. So they're they're like have access to they've got a
lot of elements to their whole country there that make them a
very big threat economically. They're very powerful economically
in a way most people don't suspect. They've got a bright economic
future. And this seems like Israel trying to attack on that front
more than on the military front. They're never going to attack
on the military front. Okay, now I have the song in my head,
the Bykar song, because I love that song. It's a good song. So,
if you guys don't know who Napali Bennett is, he's a former prime
minister of Israel. One of the times they voted um they voted
Netanyahu out. Napali Bennett was the guy who replaced him. Okay.
And and basically I I don't know. This would have been a coalition
I'm guessing.
What uh what party does he belong to?
He was in Lakood and then he was in so it would have been the
same coalition very likely right I'm guessing this would have
been the exact like he's probably still a part of the exact coalition
that would have included Netanyahu
but that he was just a different leader for that same coalition
right this is normally like a Loodled coalition but it's like
lood the home yamina new writes was what he was in before okay
I'm I'm guessing that this would be a part of the same coalition
but I don't know when seven seats
Hian government with Yay Laid. Rabbi Bennett would serve as Israel's
prime minister until 2023, after which Leed would assume the
role. Okay. So, some coalition, some right-wing coalition with
Yar Leid, although I think Leid is a centrist, right? Y laid.
Wikipedia not loading. Not cool.
Okay, I'm about to move off this page. I was just going to say,
so if you if you think that this guy doesn't matter, often people
will say, well, who is that guy? I don't know who that guy is.
What influence does he have? Well, he was just prime minister.
He was like head of state for a year, two years. Okay. So, he's
not like totally worthless. His opinions aren't worthless. He
is somebody who has influence. He's somebody who's a political
actors, a political power player in Israel. Okay? That's all.
So, often people say, "Well, what what influ what could that
guy really do?" Well, he's he's got influence. Okay. Um, from
Iranians that I've been speaking to who are from the country,
there just happens to be a few who do live there, but they were
either on holiday or they decided to leave around the time of
the protests or because things were just getting a bit too miserable.
So, they're basically able to call into my stream from wherever
they are now outside of the country. But the way that they're
talking about it and the way that their families are cuz they
they're sometimes getting Dutch, it sounds quite similar to diaspora,
right? Like there's been a lot more sort of coalesing with these
two opinions from the locals and from the people who live outside
of the country. And that's mostly happened I think just in the
last few years. Usually people in Iran who don't like the regime
were very divided. They were divided between people who were
monarchists who want the old regime back or democrats who maybe
are kind of ky about Palavi but they kind of want him as a unifying
person who can bring them democracy afterwards. And then there's
like uh there's still somewhat of like a group called the reformists
who were people who thought that Iran can be improved within
the regime's boundaries but they're basically dead now. That's
that group doesn't really exist anymore. Um but [snorts] yeah
very recently they >> Can e is there just no noise gate
possible to get rid of the sniffles?
Really? There's like nothing like couldn't he just use push to
talk for real like he could just have a button that he presses
when he wants to talk >> and much much more willing to
unify around Palavi which is kind of why uh the group is kind
of dying a little bit. >> That's the Sha's son. >> The
Sha's son. Yeah. He grew up in Iran and he's not been there for
quite a few decades now. But he's basically he he's always kind
of posed himself as a leader in waiting, but there's always just
been like this distrust around him largely because Iranians seem
to not really want the current regime, but they also are very
unsure about bringing back a monarch as well. So yeah, they're
in a difficult position and that's often been their weakness.
It's like a lack of unity. So the fact [snorts] that that's changing
is a pretty strong sign in their direction. Well, I can imagine
the people who are still in Iran after
this [snorts] horrific massacre, 30 to 40,000 people like slaughtered
in a matter of like a couple days that the tone has changed significantly
in the wake of that as well. That anyone who probably had patience
for, you know, waiting it out and stuff is probably pretty
>> dude. Just another thing to think about is 30 to 40
35 to 40,000 dead. Okay.
how bad is your strategic thinking that you do these strikes?
That was your vanguard. That was your like your your brave people
who would rise up against this regime. Those were the people.
Those were all the leaders. Everybody who could get people mobilized
and out on THE STREETS, THAT WAS THEM. That was them.
Okay?
And like so to me it's like even if you had that plan
like you just lost every single person who was brave enough to
stand up against this regime without weapons. They're all gone
which is sad. It's really sad. And there would be some people
who replace them right there. It's the same is the same issue
Israel has with Hamas where when you crack down like that you
are going to create more people who would be willing to do that.
So I'm not saying that they would be all gone but it is the same
concept. There would definitely be a lot of other people who
would be willing to rise up, but it's like you have to it's just
a a fact of life. It's a fact of human nature that humans will
not just throw away their lives unless they're like totally gone,
right? And I don't think the Iranian people by and large are
there. I I it's actually it's very rare that you ever get people
there.
Like you think about it and even the people in like the the death
camps in Germany, they they barely get there, right? Like it's
very difficult to hit a place where you're totally outmatched
and you're just willing to die on principle. Human beings will
try to live. They'll try to survive. They're animals. They'll
try to survive, right? You the the prospect of just running into
a buzzsaw of machine guns is not something that is entertaining
or or interesting to most people. So 34 30 to 40 is made up by
Israel. I don't think so. I think it's I think it's pretty reliable.
I think I've seen people who are very very anti-Israel who support
the 30,000
So they just gunn down 30,000 with machine guns. From what I
understand, they didn't just do that. They also took surveillance
of all of the protests and then they went in the days following
up. So this is Crimson Winter report on the first 50 days of
nationwide protest in Iran December to February 2026. Hale
fatalities 6,500 deceased protesters. So, these are confirmed
deceased by who?
Who are these? Is this a follow-up
Is this like I I don't know who the H is
human rights something
cuz I I saw like basically a lot of people on drop site even
which I again this is not a perfect way to collect information
but I saw even like the drop site people
kind of going along and saying like it's probably like 20 30,000
is is a good estimate. So to me when I see that well that's Hana.
I don't think H is HR the same organization as Hana is it Herana?
Okay. Okay. Okay. All right. All right. All right. I I just don't
know. So I'm trying not to make any. So 7,000. Even if it's 7,000
I do believe there are in addition to these confirmed figures
11,744
cases remain under review at the time of as of the time of writing
as their verification process has not yet been completed. These
cases are not included in the total of 707 confirmed deaths.
Various media outlets and groups have presented differing estimates
of the scale of the killings in the absence of sufficient transparency
from the Iranian government. The conditions have allowed for
the circulation of divergent statistics. In this report, Herana
emphasizes that these figures presented represent the minimum
number of confirmed cases. The actual death toll may be significantly
higher than the numbers documented by this organization. Okay.
So, I don't think I don't think
that the 20 to 30,000 is out of reasonable estimation.
Okay,
that they're saying right here that that basically like well
these these figures are the bare minimum that we have these as
confirmed figures and these are the bare minimum and the Iranian
regime has tried to hide things
No, no, no. 7,000 is the lowest possible number.
Yes.
So, I do think that 20 to 30k is possible and it fits like in
with what the regime would do. The regime is good with cracking
down on protests. And you have to think about this in another
way too. This regime has their own intelligence apparatus. This
regime is also capable of reading tea leaves. They are almost
certainly aware when these protests break out that this is a
part of a wider narrative to ferment like rebellion in their
country to manufacture consent in the west for strikes for further
war on Iran. Right? So they probably are thinking in the back
of their head, well these are just people we're going to have
to kill in a month. These are just people who are going to cause
us problems in a month, two months. I do believe that that that
would factor significantly into their decision-m to crack down
so hard on these protests when they started that they they probably
think, okay, these people are showing themselves.
We're going to have to get rid once once they actually come to
hit us and and actually like commit to a war. These are just
people who will be like a third column or a fifth column, sorry,
in our own country,
right?
Not not advocating that, not saying it's good. I'm just saying
that's almost certainly their decision-making. Okay. These people
are not stupid. They did not take this country over by being
stupid. Anyway, all right. Interesting. Okay. We go back to the
show. >> Yeah. Especially given that so Iran deals with
protests a lot. Like very very frequently. >> Iran's number
is 3,000. I could not give less about what Iran >> every
few years. Even in the 2000s, 2009 I think was a big protest
year as well. The problem is that the yeah like [snorts] I was
saying earlier in 2009 there was still a lot more discourse around
participation and like let's field more candidates for president
as in like they're all chosen they're all approved by the regime
by this ayatollah and by the guardian council but there some
are more moderate there's like the picks an endorsed candidate
but then there's the other ones who are a bit different but yeah
then in 2022 when there was the like it almost hold on it almost
seems like this that like somehow
it feels like the plan almost was something like we're going
to fment revolution we're going to give specific days to ferment
revolution.
And then it's almost like they were going to plan strikes around
that or something like that they were going to have the government
decapitated in time or around the time of these actual
actual protests
and then I wonder if something got delayed and they decided to
go anyway. Like do you know what I'm saying? cuz it doesn't make
sense to go and have these protests form and then all of your
all of the people who could possibly be your ground force get
killed
or a large portion of them and it demoralizes the country and
then you kill the Ayatollah after and now the person who's like
responsible for the crackdowns to a lot of people could be dead.
protest over that lady who was murdered uh after being arrested
for wearing her veil improperly. Even that was like the regime
wrote it off in part at least because it was mostly students
and young people demonstrating. But yeah, this most recent protest
it was significantly different because of the bizarre workers
like the people who ran the little shops. Uh and that's kind
of like a they've been kind of seen as like a backbone of Iranian
society especially in cities and that's quite significant because
in 79 it was bizarre workers who were also one of the spearheads
of the revolution. So these more working-class, usually more
conservative people being the first ones to lead the protest
against the regime was like a huge game changer, which is why
the response from the regime was so unhinged. Like people talk
about that death toll, you mentioned 30 to 40,000. Um I know
that people like to dispute it, but even if you look at the more
conservative groups that are a lot more careful and a lot more
they go through like extra extra steps of verification. Like
the lowest estimate of that death toll is like 7,000. And to
think about a country gunning down even that like 7,000 or 12
or even the lowest number in three or four days which is when
that crackdown happened there's never like try to think of a
situation in history where a country has done that to its own
people in those numbers. Chaman Square up estimates are what
2,000. You haven't seen like a crackdown like that on [snorts]
a country's own citizens who are almost all unarmed in like over
100 years. Like it's it's just been so I don't think people really
put into context just like how otherworldly that level of brutality
is from a regime like against their own citizens >> and
especially in the in the aftermath. They were going to [snorts]
hospitals and looking for people with injuries that like gunshots,
[clears throat] wounds and such and and killing them because
they're like, "Oh, you were a protester." Like it was just
>> it was just a massacre. Just heartless cold-blooded
massacre. [snorts] So, I've I've heard this. The concerning thing
for me there is when uh I I hate to point this out. It's just
tragic to point it out.
Usually, when Lonerbots disagrees with Ethan from what I've experienced,
he just remains silent instead of actually expressing disagreement.
Okay,
I'm just saying. I'm just saying. I'm just saying. This is wrong.
I literally never once defended the actions in Gaza.
I I've never once done that.
Nope. In fact, the argument I made right off the bat is Israel
Israel lies a lot and I would get out of there if I were Gazin.
I think the international community should get those people out
of there because I think it's already over. I think they are
totally planning to ethnically cleanse that area. I think it's
over for the Gazins. I think any Gazin left in that area is going
to be killed.
That's that's what I said. I said you need to help those people
flee because they are Israel will take no quarter here. They
will them up. That's what I said. And I'm sure that must have
radicalized people even even more than um they might have been
before. >> So I don't know. >> You saw what happened.
You saw what happened after the just before the American Israeli
strikes, right? I think the students were already back out in
the streets. They've been out for 5 days before Trump started
this whole fiasco. >> So what is happening inside? I I
don't do we know what's going on right now. Like are people protesting?
Are people like are they inside waiting for the strikes to um
>> it's hard to tell but I'm only ever getting drip fed
stuff from either you know Twitter videos and you know some of
them are more reliable than others on those accounts like the
joke from people. Um people that
Cost of the Iran war.
Range 1.654.
So 2 billion so far.
Okay. Sustained operations 220 million a day. 3 days. Okay.
Interesting. Very interesting. Very cool.
Let's take Oh, so just having the people there, right, with the
personnel and everything. This how much it costs. Very interesting.
Very cool. All right. 2 billion so far. Let's go. Uh, this is
the best thing you could do if you are America first in in a
genuine sense is just keep showing people the cost and have this
website. This website should be plastered everywhere. It really
should. Should be all over the place. Okay, it's way over hundreds
of billions already. Uh, I don't think so.
I do think that this probably doesn't take into account just
moving the aircraft carriers and everything into place, which
I do think is like a lot a lot of money. Like hundreds of millions
already, but it it's not way over hundreds of billions already.
It's hundreds of millions. It's way over hundreds of millions.
2000 million in fact. No, no. What did I just say? >> Yeah.
No, actually that was right. Jesus. 2000 million was technically
correct. Jesus. >> I know. Family members. as it's been
developing in the country. It seems to be that people are those
videos of people cheering and celebrating in the streets at the
death. Like that's all that's all real. I don't think there's
any disputing that. Um that mood is very real. The it seems like
the Resa Palavi is trying to direct a sort of sequence of events
in Iran. So he's currently the last thing he said to the protesters
was you can like he was encouraging them to cheer from their
windows or cheer from your cars and honk your horns and all that
to show them kind of like to drum up support. But he's effectively
doing like a stand back and stand by. He's basically saying that
there will be a point when he's going to announce that it's time
for the protesters to finish the job, which is an insanely ambitious
plan. I don't know if there's ever been a time ever when regime
change has been accomplished by a bunch of uh western powers
air strike a country, debilitate them, soften them up, and then
that paves the way for a bunch of unarmed protesters with a leader
who's not in the country to go in and finish the job. That's
a very very ambitious plan, but it seems to be what Bavi is going
for. He's convinced people that he's got like a whole plan, and
he's written a document actually of it. And he's also claiming
to have 50,000 defectors ready to go from the military. But >> wow,
that would be big. >> I mean,
it's not with one. So, the funny thing is is it's like this is
one leader. Okay, we saw the Kurd thing.
You better believe they've got people in the ears of all the
different ethnic groups there saying like, "Hey, hey, you could
like take your region. Just be your region. Don't you want to
self-determine? Just be your region." >> that's true. Yeah,
but it's we're >> the best case scenario without boots
on the ground is you can have individually in like uh individually
incentivized actors in certain regions to go and like grab do
like their own power grabs. I think just like Syria again just
like Syria pretty much. Well, do you think that this >> total
bulcanization of Iran >> the best case scenario for this?
>> A lot of the people who are expressing
concern about this are people have seen
just regime regime changes especially in the Middle East just
it just never works, right? Like you bomb a country and it just
gets worse pretty much. You got Libya, Iraq, etc., etc. Um, a
successful regime change. I don't know was the last time that
happened since World War II. But do you think that that this
could work?
>> I mean there's lots of successful regime changes. No,
it has happened a lot since World War II. There's tons of successful
regime changes. It's just you have to this could this might be
a very successful regime change. You just have to look at it
through the American lens. Like all of those regime changes that
led to people being like brutally oppressed in South America,
all of those regime changes that led to people being brutally
repressed in the Middle East, those were all those were all like
successful regime changes in the eyes of the US government. If
you mean successful in terms of like for a regime change to be
successful as in it makes the lives of the people better. The
goal of the government, the goal of the people doing the regime
change has to be that the lives of the people get better,
right? That has to be the goal. But that's almost never been
the goal in American regime change ever. That's never been the
goal in anything. >> I I really don't know. So So first
of all, people who are trying to compare this to like uh Iraq
and Libya,
these are very erroneous comparisons. Like so for one, there
there is no there isn't really any equivalent of unarmed sectarian
group armed sectarian groups that are ready to fill power vacuums
in the same way that there were in these two countries. I have
no idea who they think this um like the equivalent of Libya with
the Islamic extremists on one side and like Russian back people
on the other. Um same thing with Iraq. Like that doesn't really
exist in Iran. like Iran is a largely unarmed population. The
Kurds are armed, but they don't really they've never had ambitions
to conquer the whole country and uh rule like ISIS or um the
uh the warlords in Libya or anything like that. Um people also
forget like okay, Iraq was a failure. Uh Libya was not an attempt
at regime change. Libya was >> so I agree with Litterbox
here, but then if there are if there are no armed sectarian groups,
then you have no hope of resting power from the regime obviously
already in civil war before NATO intervened.
like
like both sides of that equation are well the entire narrative
is broken, right? If there were armed sectarian groups that have
been armed by some government, some some outside source,
then you would be doing that with a bunch of them, right? The
Kurds will rise up. Well, that's what they're being encouraged
to do. And so you but even if if there weren't, then there's
just no hope for any overthrow of that regime. >> NATO's
goal in that which was approved by the Security Council. Even
Russia didn't vote against it because they all knew Gaddafi was
Gaddafi was literally telling the opposition that he was going
to bomb the [__] out of them and calling them uh
sewer rats that needed to be exterminated and the bombing was
to basically stop that from happening. Um then Gaddafi fell and
then the British very quickly admitted that they had all kind
of either underestimated or just turned a blind eye to the Islamic
extremist groups that were armed in Libya that were ready to
fill power vacuums when Gaddafi was gone. And it but their goal
there wasn't to regime change. Their goal was to stop Gaddafi
from basically annihilating everyone in the cities that opposed
them. So, and it also doesn't mention that
I I feel like there's got to be something here that's going on
where you you do have to acknowledge that the way these power
vacuums would get filled, they they'll get filled by whoever
has the the weaponry that can win. If nobody has guns and then
the goal of like Israel and the Trump administration is just
to keep killing people with the guns and destroying equipment
as much as they can as much as possible changing the equation
consistently as long as much as that will take like weeks or
like eventually
eventually you're going to reach like a more level playing field
where people can fill those where where they will become like
the the people with weapons who can fill those power vacuums,
right? You just have to weaken things enough. But then that's
like that's a free-for-all. That that would be crazy. >> It's
not just western intervention in Libya. Russia isn't a >> like
this is this is almost an unthinkable situation
where like imagine you've basically
imagine you've basically turned a country into
I how do I not two I'm going to use my own people, okay? So I
don't sound racist. Two Native American tribes waring against
each other. Like they literally have blunt instruments and like
barely capable ballistic weapons like like slings and and arrows
literally. Okay.
Like that could be what this descends into is quite ironically
like medieval
right? If you just keep killing the people with the guns, there
will be people with guns, but like they don't have ammunition.
They're going to have like very low stock piles of ammunition
eventually, right? It would be support that's that's in the case
where nobody's armed, which
It was probably one of the most brutal warlords in the world.
So yeah, the
will be weapons that Sorry, I'm going to back it up. Sorry. There
will be weapons that find their way into that country. Okay.
That country's regime is getting totally destroyed. They're bombing
the borders. Why do you think they're bombing the borders?
Somebody said it's so they could get let the Kurds from um Iraq
in. Right. I don't even know about that. Why do you think they're
bombing border patrols, border checks?
Could be because they're trying to get other stuff into the country.
Right. Right. If that stuff's not already there. Israel built
a literal drone factory in Iran. Right. They built a literal
You think they can't smuggle things into Iran? You think they
You think they can't do that? >> And but their goal there
wasn't to >> What first people do you come from?
>> None of your business. >> To stop Gaddafi from
basically annihilating everyone in the cities that oppose them.
So, and it also doesn't mention that it's not just Western intervention
in Libya. Russia is intervening in Libya. Russia supports General
Haftar, who was probably one of the most brutal warlords in the
world. So yeah, the Libya comparison is pretty bunk. Uh the Iraq
one as well. You could also say, well, those two were failures.
Kosovo wasn't a failure. They are much better off than they were,
but before NATO intervened. Liberia was an American intervention
that went fairly well. Um Syria, for all the flaws of their current
leader, they're not going back to what happened under Assad.
Like they're still not anywhere.
>> No, Loterbox. Come on, man. There's no way Lerbox is
saying Siri's in a better position today than they were under
I I I Dude, I understand. I This is the unfortunate thing. I
You have hope for a better future, but I can't imagine. Unless
maybe they're better off now. Are the Alawites better off?
Aren't the Alawites like kind of just getting like brutally raped
on a day-to-day basis? Are the Alawites better off? My wand,
how the Alawites doing? I read some pretty nasty stories about
some persecutions of Alawites coming out of Syria.
How the alawates doing?
I'm just saying. Okay. I'm just saying how bad it was with Assad.
So each country is unique. Like the Middle East is a very very
complicated place with very very unique circumstances. And Iran
is particularly different from the rest of the Middle East because
of its history and it current situation. Um I don't know >> You
frequently hear this refrain that this type of regime change
always makes things worse. I sounds like that's not >> okay.
Stalin sloth.
Why was there civil war under Assad Jr.? This is what you have
to ask. This is what you have to ask. Why was there a civil war
under Assad Jr.? >> Not necessarily true when you if you
analyze everything on the whole. >> It doesn't have to
be worse. It could be. It could be worse in the sense that uh
one outcome potentially is the uh the Ayatollah is gone. But
then there's the youth of the IRGC who are easily the most indoctrinated,
most radicalized faction of the entire Islamic Republic. They
are the youngest generation and they are more radical and more
um hardline than the first than the first than the second and
anything. Uh and that's actually partly why they've managed to
it was quite easy for them to crack down on protesters because
these young uh security officers are just very very willing to
do whatever it takes to keep the regime in power. Uh there is
a chance that they survive the air strikes to a degree that they
can uh they can establish some kind of military dictatorship
over Iran which is worse than what we currently have.
Is there like yeah let's say before the civil war is there a
single person in Syria who's in a better position than they were
before the civil war which I would say the civil war was fermented
by people on both sides right
like I do believe the civil war was fermented by western interests
now Assad was obviously a dictator and he was willing to take
steps to crack down on his own people protesting and stuff right
obviously I'm not saying he was like a good person he's not okay
so maybe you would Hey, maybe. Yeah, like Russia was obviously
pulling back on them as well, right? Sure, sure, sure. So, okay,
the country was just totally
okay, fair enough. I
h But then, wait, then aren't we just So, correct me if I'm wrong.
We're arguing that the stability of an Islamic regime being there,
an al-Qaeda affiliated leader, okay, that that's better than
them just being in civil war and constantly getting raped.
Okay. All right. Just have to check my bases again. Okay. All
right. Good. But there's also it could also go particularly well,
right? You could have detectors from the army and from the bas
like the security forces. You could have protesters who are able
to overwhelm government buildings that have been or government
positions that have been weakened. And you can actually help
>> desisted from al-Qaeda in 2017.
Does he has his belief system changed?
>> Why did he desist from al-Qaeda? What what were the
I I would actually be interested to know what was the the change
in belief that happened from when he was with al-Qaeda. I would
be very interested to know. Maybe we got to look into the the
new Syrian leader
because they wanted to force him to attack the West.
He just wanted to kill Assad. >> Coming in this plan working
is >> well. Oh, sorry. the so none of the underlying beliefs
of like how you would govern, you know, might makes rights. We
want dictatorships with a warlord, me in charge. None of that
stuff has changed. It's just
Yeah. Okay. So, he's still an Islamist. Yeah, that's what I was
getting at. So, it's still like
theocratic rule for the people, right?
He wants a democracy. Okay. >> It's a very if Iran had
a president, I would completely support it because, >> it's
it's hard to it's hard to overestimate just how bad the current
state of affairs is, right? People talk about destabilizing.
What is it? Was was it unstable when they murdered at least 7,000
of their own people in three days? Like no, not really. I mean,
what what is stable here? Um, at some point there does kind of
need to be a change. So, >> it's just a very real shame
that you've got Trump and HexF leading the charge right now.
>> That's a good point. Yeah.
>> How does how does he manage
you'd never know this, right?
How does he manage his own like militia?
Is that democratic? Is it has he shown like a lot of democratic
sympathies in any way? Are there are there real indications he's
moving the country towards democracy as well? >> They're
kind of the least competent,
>> most cynical presidents you could have to do it. [laughter]
Um, this is a video, by the way, of when the news hit Iran that
the Ayatollah was was killed, just to give you an idea. >> What
the
>> That's like universal rejoicing. There's like if you
were afraid that there was people that dis a people that disagree
with you,
I don't think you would see this type of universal just celebrating
in the streets. It just seems like the vast majority of people
in Iran are happy to to throw the dice and try to improve [clears throat]
their situation. But also on top of that, like Iran is so up
like the inflation has gone crazy
>> because of the basically I don't know the Ayatollah
just sends a their money to
fund terrorism. It just seems like their current situation was
just totally unlivable, just not sustainable at all. >> Um
yeah, and it's been like that for a while. Iran is when people
talk about dictatorships, there's something that is probably
worth remembering is that not all dictatorships are unpopular.
Um, China for example is a dictatorship, but I'm pretty sure
most people in China are either okay with or indifferent to or
actually just supportive of the CCP. Like China doesn't really
have to worry that much about um getting like anything like what's
happening in Iran. Lots of dictatorships are like that. Iran
is exceptional in how different the population is from the regime
and it's been like that for for a really really long time. The
even if you consider how the regime came into power do you want
to go do you mind if I take a minute to go into that? >> Okay.
So like the Ayatollah the first one Kmeni was he obviously came
from like a very very devout religious background. His initial
uh work was him preaching and writing about uh mysticism and
things like that. Um before the Ayatollah the Sha was obviously
he came in through an American and British backed coup like the
CIA and British intelligence did not like the government in Iran
led by Mosedc they didn't like the country nationalizing oil
that they thought was theirs for whatever colonial reasons. So
they overthrew him through the CIA and the sha was basically
there to effectively do their bidding like he was there to westernize
the country. He put in all these reforms to try to like modernize
Iran but very much in the image of America and the UK and Europe
and the Ayatollah was very dissatisfied by this obviously mostly
for religious reasons because he believed that western uh influence
or any foreign influence would degrade Islamic society. He was
like very much like a purist in that sense that ever since the
he would argue since the seventh or 8th century Islam has been
as soon as Islam started to bring in influences from other dynasties
and other empires that it started to weaken itself. And then
obviously this kind of seeing this display of what he saw as
western arrogance and opulence and um plundering of the wealth
and uh people getting very wealthy and very uh sort of like modernized
but only confining to a very small amount of people in the country
right most of the country didn't see the benefits of westernization
under the sha so he sees all this and he's very very offended
but to begin with he he actually struggled to really make it
click with the rest of the population so if you look at what
he talks about in the 50s
>> where's the lie I don't know what the lie would be I'
I'm honestly just getting thrown off by Ethan. >> A lot
of it is it's specifically like a religious attack on the sha.
So he's talking he one of the things he spoke about quite a bit
was women's skirts. He didn't like you've seen the pictures of
the Iranian students. Yeah. He was very offended by like women's
skirts and like what the he would talk about the length in a
very derogatory way and he would uh because he believed that
women doing that would distract the men from their religious
duties. But it wasn't until the 60s when it was 64 or 63 I think
when he came up with a speech that was in response to a law that
was passed by the sha that granted immunity to American personnel
in the country. And it meant that an American soldier or a diplomat
or a family member if they committed a crime in Iran they could
not be prosecuted by the sha because they didn't trust this justice
system. They had to get judge they could either get judged in
America or not at all. So he writes this thing and usually how
did that come into place? >> The sha passed it. just put
it into place. Why? Because he was he was >> Did he do
so democratically? He's like an American puppet leader effectively.
>> that seems like an obscenely
crazy law to just say check to any American to do whatever they
want. >> It's a very old imperial thing to do. The Ottoman
Empire used to do this as well. They used to do it for citizens
of European countries. They would call them the capitulations.
>> I mean, America basically has this for the globe, right?
This is sort of what the the is it the it's not the heg it's
the heg doctrine. the whatever like if we're being tried in international
courts actually we're just going to invade you automatically
like we have a law or we reserve the right to invade you automatically
right like we don't we don't respect international courts American
court like America sort of has this kind of thing right sorry
American
legal doctrine invasion of the >> in order to trade with
richer countries >> that doesn't mean they automatically
invade I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure it's just like we have
a thing here to let you know that like if it's against our interest
we will to get security from richer countries, they would concede
little things like that to basically just keep trade relations
and keep in the good books. >> I can see that being a very
like
upsetting law and and just really weird for the for someone who's
representing the people to pass a law that says >> Yeah.
And the the Ayatollah was usually quite cy about naming America
specifically in his speeches because of the risks and he would
talk about Israel by any but not America. um he would usually
just say foreign influence but in this speech he names America
very very directly and he has this like really powerful line
in the speech where he basically says that because of these laws
they have reduced the Iranian to below the level of an American
dog right and it's very inflammatory it stirs up a lot of uh
uh sort of word in the press and everything and he's he ends
up being exiled for basically just stirring up too much and he
was very very insulting towards the sha he belittled him quite
a lot effectively became quite obsessed with the Ayatollah because
he just didn't know how to deal with So spends the rest of his
time in France before the revolution. And when he's there, he's
kind of realized that this kind of language like anti-imperial
um anti- opulence or anti-w is starting to branch out beyond
the religious crowd. Now he's appealing to people who are uh
leftwing, okay? Like there's a lot of Soviet influence at this
time. He's appealing to communist parties like the two-day party
in Iran. He's appealing to even liberal-minded people. And this
is that's kind of like his calling card. And there's this whole
sequence of events throughout the 60s and 70s where he is effectively
saying multiple things to different groups of people. So when
he's talking to the religious crowd in Iran through his uh proxies
and everything, he's uh talking about this whole theory that
he has like this grand theory called the theatel fak which is
like the it's called like the governance of the jurist. See Ayat
the Ayatollah was mad snarking on the Shaw. Okay. Yes. The Ayatollah
was insanely he was insanely snarky. He's snarking on the Shaw
and his decisions all the time. >> This idea that Islamic
clerics should be in charge of basically governing society, that
they're the ones to guide the Muslim world until like the coming
of the 12th imam or whatever. Um, and it's a and he illegally
like smuggles these pamphlets of his ideas around the country
and it's like it's a proper like medieval
manifesto basically like he's talking about uh flogging people
for drinking alcohol. He's talking about stoning women for adultery.
He's talking about uh hard and swift justice and like he's you
know scathing attacks on like the western due process kind of
thing. Uh he is talking about how it's not just Israel. It's
not just colonialism. It's actually that Islam
Ethan didn't just think Wait, what did he say?
What is that
of due process? It's a Yeah. Yeah. Western
the way you say that is a Scottish person with the accent which
is funny. constant hundreds three or 400 year war against the
who are trying to he says not Zionist or anything who are trying
to corrupt the Islamic world and weaken it and they're getting
backed by other satanic forces like the United States. But then
when he's talking to the west he's talking about imperialism.
He's talking about this country is not ours. He's talking about
liberating from uh western powers. He's talking about plundering.
He's talking about extraction of wealth. He's reassuring Western
journalists that he actually wants like an Islamic democracy.
um he never mentions any of these texts that he's passing around
in Iran, which is actually why a lot of uh leftwing intellectuals
of the time, especially in France, were either like curious about
him in like a positive way or just in some cases, some of them
were just really supportive. Most of them were just kind of like,
oh well, this is a bit odd, but you know, better than the than
the SHA. So when he came to power in 79, one of the reasons he
was able to was because he convinced the Carter administration
in part to to help him. like the sha was refusing to leave the
country. There was a risk of a civil war that would have broken
out to keep the sha in power. But Carter kind of smoothed over
that transition to allow the ayat to return to Iran and take
control. And now we know that from a few like league documents
that he was literally writing to the state department convincing
them that we wouldn't try to export the revolution. We're trying
to establish an Islamic democracy. We're going to uh don't worry
about oil and all that. You know, we need money. We're going
to be trading. We're willing to open our arms to the rest of
the world. So he makes all these promises and then obviously
breaks like every single one of them as soon as he comes into
power. Um and in 79 he kidnaps a bunch of US embassy workers.
That starts the hostage crisis. That's when the sanctions started.
And also anyone who's helped them come to power including the
leftwingers in Iran. He starts murdering them. Um very very
>> Classic. Classic. Hey there's a some communists over
there. You want to go kill them? Thank you. Thank you. Go kill
the communists. Dude, every time like clockworks is very funny.
Just the Shaw's like the Shaw is taking over. I'm sure the Shaw
came into power and was like, "Oh, kill those communists." And
then the Ayatollah comes in. They're like, "Finally, we could
get revenge for for the oh god, they're they're shooting us.
They're shooting us." >> And then one by one, all people
start to have uh a sort of curious aura around him. Just are
disillusioned immediately. >> And the scale of how quickly
this happened is like really >> uh jarring. Like the sha
was not a good leader. He had a secret police. He was also kind
of anti-Semitic. He said that America was run by the lobby to
American interviewers. He um he murdered about three or 4 hundred
of his political opponents in throughout the 70s when he was
facing opposition. The Ayatollah outdid that in like less than
a year. >> He immediately comes into power and within a
few months he sets up these um these criminal uh councils where
these these tribunals where their goal their stated goal is to
just completely crush any enemies. They said to exterminate dissident
who stand against the imam, to kill them and torture them to
death and to execute anyone who stands against the republic.
So within a few within a few months he's setting up these tribunals
where these religious judges are basically serving sometimes
as prosecutors, interrogator, executioner, and the jury like
one person doing all of it. And he starts murdering people in
the hundreds and eventually the thousands within a couple of
years. And the only reason he really manages to stay in control
is probably because of the Saddam's invasion of Iraq of Iran.
Saddam invaded Iran in 81 and then that was what gave them the
green light to sort of keep this martial law environment going
long enough to get rid of all his opposition. >> So you
think the people of Iran,
>> dude, what was the what was the pretext for Saddam Hussein
invading Iran? I actually don't know. Like why what did he say
his reason was? where a lot of them were bamboozled into supporting
the Hayyatollah more than they would have because he was basically
lying to a lot of people about his intentions. >> Yeah,
there was a real hoodwink going
>> Is Lunerbach saying the Sha wasn't that bad? I don't
think he's saying he wasn't that bad. I think he's saying he
was less bad than the current Islamic Republic, which seems to
be the case.
Right there. There is a thing where you where when you're an
American puppet, you aren't going to be better than some dictators
because the American people won't continue to support your country's
support, right? Sorry, the the American people won't continue
to support America supporting that country if you're like too
crazy. So, there probably is some effect there. It's like whether
or not that's like a good reason to keep somebody in power. >> And
yeah, and also just the fact that like he um yeah, he spoke out
of both sides of his mouth. the way he spoke to western press
was so different from the way he spoke to uh his own hardline
followers and yeah just also a combination of just like sheer
brutality the circumstances of the time and also yeah just being
kind of deceptive in order to stay in power. What's interesting
is that um this is kind of like the beginning of what we see
today I suppose in what you call like I guess you ever heard
that the red the red green alliance. You ever heard that >> Never
the idea. So red being for communist and green being for Islamic
>> Oh heard of Islamo or Islamic communism or something
like that? Yeah. >> Yeah. And it makes it makes so little
sense like what do these ideologies have in common with each
other. But Ayatollah was very he was very clever. He was very
good at using a lot of this mauist and like leftist rhetoric
to sort of win people over. And Western leftists at the time
actually were not as convinced of it as a lot of people are now.
But the party in Iran, the Communist Party that was Soviet backed,
they supported it actually even while he was murdering them.
There's a really odd uh interview that two of the Iranian communist
activists who >> Well, yeah, cuz they're probably getting
money from the Soviets. Yeah. And the Soviets wanted the Shaw
out, right? Like the Sha would have been totally rejecting everything
the Soviets offered them, every every bit of Soviet influence,
right?
So obviously he would have just were out of the country gave
where they were literally defending the revolution even as their
leader is being tortured and forced to confess to a bunch of
fake crimes on television. He Yeah. So he managed to uphold that
quite well. And obviously throughout the you know throughout
the coming decades they were always able to do this thing where
they would speak two different languages right that's why when
you hear about the Islamic Republic talking to people in the
west they're always talking about imperialism colonialism Zionism
uh using especially like the mauist language that he used to
use was uh talking about how people who have like a very like
working class and a very back to basic or strip back lifers like
are demonstrating a level of purity that was that's like a very
mauist message attacking opulence things like that of the western
world it's a very mauist as well. So yeah, he they were always
very good at messaging in that sense.
[clears throat] >> A lot of the opposition I'm seeing is
from leftists. I think liberals I've seen who are critical of
it are more so [snorts] um concerned about just Trump basically
just unilaterally creating a war like most likely illegal. And
so I think a lot of people are hesitant based on based on that.
Like you said, if it was [clears throat] any other president,
there would probably be a lot more support for it. But Trump
has no one's trust essentially outside of his most >> What?
Wait, HOW DO WE GET TO THAT? WAIT, WHAT? It's Dude, I'm sorry.
I just like
like there's there's actual nuance to what the things that Loterbox
says and then Ethan just comes in with that. And I I just got
to see Lerbox's response cuz I I don't think that's true. I'm
I'm positive that's not true. I'm literally positive it would
be even less popular. At least Trump has like a syphant
following that will support anything he does, right? But for
everybody else, I don't think that's the case. >> More
support for it. But Trump has no one's trust essentially outside
of his most diehard
supporters. So I'm seeing two things like people who are distrustful
of the American well Trump's administration obviously, which
is which I agree with. And then the other one is
>> don't don't don't please don't say anti-semitic people
who are distrustful of everything involving Israel. Please don't
say that. Please don't reduce it to that. Please don't reduce
it to that. Please don't reduce it to that. You make your entire
arguments from earlier in the past like two years looks so stupid
if you reduce it to that. There's no way he could possibly reduce
it to that. It couldn't possibly be done. >> Almost like
when I see Hassan and folks like him talk about it, it seems
like he's pro he's pro Ayatollah. He won't come out and say it,
but essentially
he was good with the status quo. It seemed like cuz whenever
it was like talking about the protesters, they're always toying
with the idea there was some kind of Zionist plot or there's
some kind of a like a agents that are making creating unrest
in the country. So it's I don't
>> I mean there that was also happening. All things could
be true at the same time. It just seems like they like the status
quo there and a lot of what they're doing is to downplay the
severity of the Ayatollah's rule. >> We might have to check
this out. >> And downplaying the um the the genuine um
celebrating at least for the time being of the of the Persian
people in and out of Persia
kind of trying to >> I don't downplay I literally believe
that the Persian diaspora who fled because they hate this regime.
I perfectly well believe that they're very happy about >> downplay
what what seems to be
uh reality and so [cough] I feel I don't I really don't know
how to interpret the conversation outside of my bubble cuz I
don't really take in much mainstream disc I don't even know where
this kind of mainstream discourse takes place you could put on
CNN you could put on Fox News but online on Twitter um I think
does influence and Tik Tok influences how young people feel about
these issues and a lot of what I see there is domin minated by
the leftist
like a lot of a lot of uh >> I think
yeah I mean I completely sympathize with the with the liberal
skepticism of it in the sense that it's a very incompetent regime
it's a very incompetent leadership in America doing it like I
wouldn't trust Trump or exist to sit the right way in a toilet
seat right let alone go and do something like that it's such
a again it's such a bold plan like no one's ever done anything
like this before if it succeeds it's obscenely complicated what
they're trying to do
>> okay let's Just let's just be real. They did not plan
for this. They objectively did not given the statements today,
we know they did not plan for regime change. That was not the
plan they had. The plan they had was to take one of the the number
two guy, the number three guy and put them into power. It was
just going to be a strike on on Kmeni. They were looking to do
the Venezuela thing. Israel changed the equation
that they America had no clue about any kind of regime change
and now they're on their heels. They're going to the [__]
K herds in Iraq trying to get them to go in and invade, right?
It's like they they had no plan. >> And you got Hex just
today talking about the stupid rules of engagement like no more.
He might I was half expecting him to call rules of engagement
gay or something like it was just so >> That guy is legendarily
stupid uh and unqualified. It's Oh, Dan's going to send me the
quote. >> But I have a question about that. Do you think
that maybe this is something that's already been
um like in some sort of a plan for many years? Because >> Well,
the funny thing is 79,
guess who guess who hates uh Resa Palavi the most?
Do you think it's the people in the major cities?
It is not. It is not. Where he pulls the absolute worst in that
whole country is with the ding ding ding the Kurdish people.
the people who they're now trying to get boots on the ground
through the Kurdish people to get into that country to go and
take things over. That's the guy who is least liked, would be
least appreciated by the Kurdish people. Very cool. >> There's
like it's been known that Iran is the cause of so much trouble
that even though Trump or whoever is in charge or the person
people in charge, there's actually knowledgeable people heading
the attack and they have like planned this over years or I mean
>> Yeah. I mean, obviously yours [laughter] >> that
might be true because people outside of the American government
are planning and leading this attack. That could be true actually
that they've been planning it for years and those people have
been doing it. Okay,
they'll install the MEK and not the Shaw. Well, I think it was
Pompeo who's who's boosting the MEK, right? Recently, wasn't
Pompeo out here like boosting the MEK directly?
Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Sorry. Quan said uh they'll install the
MK, not the Shaw. I I still don't know
if any of this works. I don't know that they're going to I don't
know that they're going to have the ability to install anybody.
You will have to to get the IRGC out, to get the Islam Islamic
Republic out, you're going to have to degrade the the overall
like military capacity in any way in that country so much that
like, bro, I feel like I feel like other groups have to have
ways of influencing this, right?
understand this quite well. Like um obviously in Israel like
you can have half the nation or more than half the nation hating
Netanyahu but they'll still say like 90% of us support the IDF,
right? Yeah. Because they trust that there's a difference there
and there's the competency isn't actually spread equally. I mean
it obviously is partly the same in the United States. I think
the difference is is how much it's how much uh overstep and how
much people like Trump and Hex have tried to get involved in
the American system, right? Like Pex giving his little speech
to all the generals telling them that no one's allowed to be
fat anymore overweight. Everyone apart from the commander-in-chief,
by the way, because Trump is literally like I'm pretty sure if
you put a pin in that guy, he would burst and you just get showered
in like a [__]
semi digested McDonald happy meals but like yeah I so that that's
maybe a bit of a difference and that I don't know if you know
about that you know about the strike on that school
>> is there any chance the 50,000 IRGC defector number
is real
I mean I can't say for sure I would imagine the IRGC from what
I've heard the IGC is incredibly like it's not militant just
in a military sense they're militant in like a belief sense they
are fanatical that that's like how you get put in the IRGC so
to have like widespread defection from the IRGC right Now, right
after the Ayatollah is killed, I cannot see it. I really really
cannot see it.
But like I can't say no cuz I don't know for sure. But it just
seems it it belies
>> Yeah. I I went >> Can you talk about that because
I've seen so much about it that I don't know what's real and
what's not. >> Um so what we know is >> just to be
clear if people don't know this in the very beginning of the
bombings a school for young girls was blown up and a lot of children
died. like 100 plus children died, >> which is obviously,
you know, heartbreaking for everybody and upsetting to everybody
and everybody wants to point fingers, right? >> Yeah, it's
Well, it was definitely
box. I'm really hoping that you got some counter evidence for
this that it wasn't Israel or the US that did it. So, I'm just
going to open this up and then I'm going to let you talk. Please,
please. We know that it was definitely some distance away from
a uh IRGC base. >> In fact, all buildings in the country
are some distance away from an IRGC >> Uh, apparently,
it used to be one. I'm not sure how 100% that is, but it seems
like it's fairly credible. We don't actually know how far away
it was. I saw a bunch of Twitter oent [snorts] accounts saying
it's only like 50 meters away or 10 meters away. Uh it seems
like it's more like there was a few hundred, like five or six
hundred meters away. Uh I don't know which Israeli or American
bomb has that much of a radius. Like like every bomb has like
a range that it can miss by, right? Even your guided Jammu, they
can still miss by like 30 or 50 meters. I don't know what can
miss by 600. I'm not aware of whatever weapon
>> I think whoever blew up the school must have meant to
do it cuz it's just right.
It's so transparent what Ethan's saying there, right? It's insanely
transparent what he's saying there.
Oh my goodness. That's crazy. That's crazy stuff.
That's wild.
because the other side of it as well is that uh people overestimate
even in people overestimate like military intelligence you know
like in the it's come a long way like say in the in the first
in the Iraq war in 2003 you know like on day one of that war
they went for about 55 targets all decapitation like heads of
the regime and in Saddam included they were tracked with GPS
and you know top of the range like tracking phone signals every
single strike missed >> wow way wide and it was all in
cities as well so they whenever they the missiles landed on just
been pulled out. >> That's [__] up. >> Yeah.
Um >> although I assume technology's improved. >> Yeah,
of course it's improved. It's improved massively, but it's still
it's still far from perfect. So it's more likely something like
an intelligence failure or like a mis targeting. >> Okay,
you could say I think Loaderbox is basically saying that what
he thinks happened is I'd never crab Burchch it, but that's cool.
You should watch it. Um
I think what he's saying here is
that what he thinks happened is a is an intelligence failure.
So they basically blew it up intentionally, but they didn't realize
there were kids there. I Okay, I don't think so. But >> potentially
if they especially if it used to be part of a compound and going
by old intel, but I can't imagine like
my my brain keeps telling me that someone like Hexath has loosened
rules of engagement to allow some of that to happen. I don't
know why because it seems like the consensus now is that it was
more likely an American than an Israeli strike because of how
each side has responded to the claims. It could have also been
neither. It could have been a stray missile from Iran. It could
have been an interception and that's why it fell short. Yeah,
we're not going to know probably until maybe several weeks after
the fact. But it does to me point >> to me it points like
either more likely America but maybe America or Israel just being
a little bit too loosey goosey with their targeting which is
quite which is discriminal. Like I don't know why the fact that
it was the first wave of strikes. Why is if your first wave of
strikes is near a school? Why why are you doing that? Like when
would you want if you're going to strike targets I would imagine
that you would go after the more obvious ones first and then
>> Well no no no. You just your previous thing you said
kind of discounts that right? that you there's no way you could
believe that
it sounds like he believes there's an American or Israeli munition
and that no Israeli American munition that they'd be using here
has a like error rate of as far as it so it was intentional
right
you can't you can't say
>> I don't know why the fact that it was the first wave
of strikes why is if your first wave of strikes is near a school
why why are you doing that like would you want if you're going
to strike targets I would imagine that >> they were intentionally
striking it though was the first thing stated Why would you strike
a Well, cuz they were intentionally striking it. It can't be
an intelligence failure. And you know, why would you shoot near
a school? >> We go after the more obvious ones first and
then if one is near a school, then at least that's when you would
>> You see why people dislike him? Um I see why people
are mad at him. Yeah. Because it feels to me like he's
Well, I think these are his opinions. I understand why people
get angry or annoyed. I don't mind that he describes things this
way. I don't mind that he like um has these opinions. The thing
that actually upsets me is when I could tell that he can tell
what Ethan's kind of saying sometimes and then he will respond
with like silence. He doesn't want to necessarily like go in
and like correct Ethan. That's what more annoys me is is areas
where I think he could jump in. And like here,
I think he basically I think what he did here was he soft corrected
Ethan on basically saying that like it's very unlikely that it
is
like he he's saying it's possible, but it's unlikely that it's
the interception or an IRGC rocket missile, whatever, right?
That's likely a US or or Israeli one. And it seems like maybe
more likely >> Expect like there's be after you've already
struck other places and there are sirens going off. people have
chances to evacuate cuz I imagine after the first strikes kids
at school would have had to go home and then bases that are near
the schools would be much easier to target. But um yeah, I know
something something sounds very very wrong about how that happened.
>> It's horrible. It's just it's so
>> I unfortunately you'll never convince me that whatever
country struck this building didn't also have satellite images
of kids going into that building for like weeks leading up to
it. Okay, I'm sorry. They obviously do. They obviously would.
Do not do not try to pretend that you would never ever understand
that there would be kids going to that school that it was operating
as a school now,
right? You would have satellite imagery. You would be able to
see what's going on with that school. I've heard tell that they
actually had like CCTV in a lot of Iran that like basically a
lot of Iran is not operating on very new technology. So anywhere
that had CCTV set up, they were basically tapped into stuff.
Okay. Why would the USA or Israel intentionally target that school
and only that school? I don't know. I don't know what happened
here, but I'm telling you. So, in the case where it's an intelligence
failure, I think there is something where there's got to be like
checks and balances, checks like checks in your process so that
you don't go and bomb a school that like you could have intel
and then you would be like, "Okay, because we have intel on these
targets, we actually want to step through and look at like satellite
footage of these targets and see and make sure like our like
we're going to do some sort of check on these targets, right?"
So, if you wanted to say, here's here's a possibility. Okay,
Israel forced this strike. Israel let the US know um the US was
not planning to participate on strikes this day. Perhaps they
had to go grab targets and and like break past some barriers
on on due diligence, right? And or yeah, possibly AI greasing
through targets or something, bro. If that comes out, could you
imagine if that comes out that basically like they just threw
target selection for this building like through some AI that
was going to evaluate like satellite photos or something and
then it came back and was like, "Yeah, it's it's all good." Bro,
you're biased. So now you want to believe the worst. You're completely
lost. You telling me I'm biased? As I'm running through like
the apologia for the American government
of why they struck this. So here's the thing. braid.
Lot just said his strongest belief was that this was intentional
and probably an intelligence failure. That's what Loterbox just
said. Is he lost? Because I'm describing the exact same thought
process. I'm still manning that thought process.
So if you say I'm just completely lost because I'm still banning
Lonerbox's thought process. If you think Lonerbox is lost, I
don't know how much further I could get
like towards the center than where Loner Box is right now. Like
I I already disagree with him a lot and I'm literally stealing
his thought process. And you go, "No, bro. You're just biased
now. You want to believe the worst now."
Really? Go back and listen. I'm literally steelmaning loner box's
thought process. Wait, did Loner Loner said it? He he believes
it has to be intentional because there is no US munition that
will strike. No US or Israeli munition that has a an error rate
of like 500 m or 600 m. And then I literally proposed a reason
why they might not have done that
if you'd been continuing to listen cuz I was thinking through
things out loud, which is what this stream is. If you listen
to two seconds of of me talking and don't listen the whole way
through and just get really reactive and emotional, then you're
going to have a hard time with this stream. It's maybe maybe
there's some somewhere else where they're going to coddle your
feelings and you can like feel safe most of the time. Probably
not here. Okay. >> Well, that just happens. It's just so
it's just
America and Israel in this war. Like this is the worst if this
is what they're just they're losing the war immediately just
like blowing up school. It just doesn't get worse than that.
100 kids. It's just
upsetting. Here's the quote from Hegith. He said no stupid rules
of engagement. Oh, it was America then. He said there's no rules
of engagement. That's really >> that's actually really
dark.
>> I mean >> this is the thing as well when you operate
when you go do this. This is all America continued to degrade
its own international reputation at the behest of Israel. By
the way, America looks terrible. America are the people engaging
in fake peace talks to try to get these people lulled into a
sense of security. America are the ones going back on their word.
Now, America are the ones who are being made out as the people
who killed the kids.
America are the ones who look incompetent. America are the ones
who now we it's been made clear that they got dragged along.
Right? It's all a degradation of the American reputation, American
exceptionalism
for the arandisement of
So I hope you guys understand that every step of the way you
degrade your country to
buoy the the standing, the reputation, the safety of Israel.
Oh, also also also
this is a quick reminder.
Also, you're footing the bill for all of this. Also, you're footing
the bill for all of it.
Good luck. Good luck. Good luck. >> The only thing we got
there is that like I think Sencom from America said that they
were uh they were looking into it. The IDF just said they they
didn't they weren't operating in that area. So there was like
one Oent account like actually a leftwing one uh that was saying
there was more like an American one. But I don't know. It's uh
to me I feel like AXF has got his fingerprints all over that
is my instinct. >> So he said no super rules [snorts] of
engagement, no nation building quagmire, no democracy building
exercise, no political correct wars. He said we fight to win.
We don't waste time or lives. As the president warned, an effort
of this scope will include casualties. Jesus Christ. You remember
what Hex was doing before he became before he had his [snorts]
role when he was a Fox News >> He was he was campaigning
to under Trump won. He was campaigning to get people who had
been either tried or convicted of war crimes pardoned. >> So
he's a big fan of >> Yeah. Like like literally US guys
who were found guilty of opening fire on civilians in Iraq. One
guy was like a marine who threatened to kill his own guys if
they told him and got him pardoned. Yeah. He is a >> You
might say his platform is pro war crime. He's the war crime guy.
That's >> That's crazy. >> Yeah. That's pretty concerning.
I mean that kind of underlines why [snorts] it's not good that
Trump's the one doing this. is just a government of bad faith,
mean, evil, incompetent people. It's really something. [snorts]
>> I will say that despite um
yeah, it's a real shame that it just had to happen like in this
way. I just I just really hope that
there's our hold on. Sorry, I had to walk away for a second.
There is our final sorry our final our first deviation from Israel
like criticisms that would apply or or descriptors that would
apply to America or sorry to to America only and not Israel.
Okay, there's our first differentiation. Israel is evil. They
are conniving but they are not incompetent. Okay, that's the
only difference. The American regime is all those things too
but incompetent on top of it. Yes. on the complete freak chance
[snorts] that things go. I mean, the first day as far as their
targeting uh of the people they wanted to kill went like they
got the day one, the Iranian missiles [snorts] are just so much
more limited than they thought they were that the regime clearly
feels like this is the end of themselves. Like I don't know why
else they decided to spend the first day constantly lobbing drones
at at hotels in Dubai. That just seems very >> I found
that I found that to be a very odd strategic choice. >> They're
like bombing like the bird uh
It's It's not actually it's it's like it's not a great basically
I do think this is their best way to create like a window for
the rest of the world.
And how do I describe this? Like basically for the rest of the
world to put maximum pressure to stop this. That's what they're
trying to do, right? That's their strategic goal is we're going to
make this as expensive for the entire planet as we possibly can.
We're going to with things as much as we possibly can. We're
going to make it so the Islam the Islamic world is upset. The
whole globe is upset. We're going to piss everybody off. It also
spreads America's defenses. No. Um you could argue it's so there
there is something here Josh Kosh where basically to stop these
missiles from landing you have to use more expensive harder to
produce technology right for interceptors.
like the ballistic missiles that they're firing are actually
like this is possibly the one way you could maybe justify attacking
them as well is is all of those ballistic missiles, all the cruise
missiles they make, every single missile they make is like far
cheaper to make for them than it is to make an interceptor that
can knock that down. And so by continuing to fire all these missiles
and and soak up interceptor, it's all increasing costs for everybody
around, right? That's what Iran is trying to do. They're basically
spamming like super high efficiency things all over the place
trying to make it so that it costs as much as possible for everybody
like maximal maximizing cost for everyone else. Okay.
20 to 50k for one of those drones for the shahads. Each missile
is 30k. Each interceptor is 250k. It's like a mathematical equation
now. Yeah. But Tequila Sunset, that's basically what they're
doing is they're going to maximize the cost of everything for
everybody and make it so that is it's super super super costly
for every single everybody everybody involved in this, everybody
who co-signs this to get pressure on Israel and America to stop
that Iran stops right now. I do think Iran will run out of production
and will run out of like everything before they can truly break
America. But America, it's not about breaking America. It's about
making the American people go, "Oh, like we don't want this anymore.
Stop. Stop now." Which I think for the right, they're basically
there already.
There's like basically there's this I guess for the horseshoe,
they're already there. For the there's like this um neoliberal
neoonservative coalition who probably do support it, but I think
I think that coalition's getting smaller and smaller every day.
They do stuff like this. >> And other like luxury hotels
and >> it wasn't the Khalifa, it was another >> No,
they also hit the Khalifa, I think. I think I was confused by
that too. It's another building also called Burge something.
They want to look for a sale. >> got two Burge. >> They
got multiple >> Bur. So I was like, isn't this just going
to they're just going to lose sympathy with all these other countries
that were, you know, trying to
>> they're going to lose sympathy with all these and I
don't say this like I I like that a bunch of Sunni Arab countries
are allied with the US. Okay, this is good. But it's like the
Shia the Shia regime is going to lose the goodwill they had from
all of these Sunni regimes around
just the most ignorant statement you could possibly make. All
of the Sunni regimes with American bases are not going to have
any goodwill towards the Shia regime who they hate. There's no
goodwill remaining, guys.
[snorts] >> Yeah, there was um there is there is like a
logic to it from their perspective and it's basically that they
just want there to be enough. They just want to spread the atmosphere
of chaos like as widely as possible uh to sort of fire people
up in the region. So, it's funny how that you can you learn so
much about uh Middle Eastern factions when you see how different
countries have reacted, right? Saudi and the Emirates and Qatar
are all very furious. Saudi I think are still are threatening
to actually back at Iran which is quite scary because if you
talk about hex targeting Saudi air in Yemen only hit like a third
of their targets. So they're a complete state. [laughter] >> Dude,
I said this to somebody I think it was Tisa in chat earlier in
Discord earlier today. I was like dude give give the Saudis another
10 years of like just trying to trying to knock down mud huts
in Yemen in Yemen. Okay. Yemen many mud huts. And maybe they'll
figure it out. Okay. We got to give them another decade of using
like F-16s to try to to try to take down. They literally have
F-16s. They've got like the highest level munitions from the
US. Okay. And they can't knock down onetory mud huts in Yemen.
It's embarrassing. Okay. It's
>> But then you look at Iraq and people are quatory of
people trying to storm the US embassy because obviously >> no
wonder No wonder the Houthies thought that they could take on
the US government. Okay. No wonder they thought that. They're
like, "Oh, we've seen what you could do with US weapons. You
guys miss all the time.
>> We see what you could do with that. That's not very
much. Oh, actually Saudi Arabia is just like legendarily incompetent.
>> Shia and they have no love for the United States because
of the last 20 years. Um Bahrain as well is like a Shia country
or like a large population of Shia so they're more supportive.
But then you see somewhere like >> Oh, okay. So Bahrain
but Bahrain is an American collaborator, right? Like Bahrain
is a straight up like they've got one of the biggest military
bases in the region there, do they not?
One of the biggest US military bases in the region. So like I
it it does trend into American collaboration probably where uh
they are probably the most pro America people in the Arab world
because of because America helped them when Saddam invaded. Uh
you saw those three planes that got shot down by mistake the
three American jets and Kuwaiti citizens coming down to the pilots
who landed.
>> I saw a clip of one of the one of the pilots had to
>> Dude Kuwaiti Kuwait better be thankful to America. Bro,
if Kuwait doesn't love America, then like America should just
actually take dire measures to make sure the the Middle East
doesn't exist anymore. If Kuwait can't love America, then nobody
in the Middle East is capable of loving America. Okay. America
has spent unfathomable
amounts of money making sure the Kuwaitis are okay. >> Parachute
out. >> And one of the Kuwaitisians.
>> There was three different planes that got shot. >> How
did How did that happen? >> I thought it was just one.
>> Those planes are expensive, man. >> I Oh, they're
F-15s, too, which is one of my favorite fighter jets. Just to
be a nerd a little bit, >> there's not there's not that
many of them, but the guy >> in the video that I saw, the
guy >> All of them [clears throat] survived >> Yeah,
they all ejected.
>> They survived and then they were met by locals on on
the floor. Yeah. >> So, what happened when they were met
by >> Here's a report. Here's an exclusive report we have.
>> Dude, first the locals were like concerned that they
were actually downed from Iranian fighter jets. You see the picture?
I think I showed it on stream yesterday, but it might have been
really late. See the picture of the guy with the pipe? like the
pipe behind his back as he's walking up to the American pilot.
[laughter] >> I'm from No Jumper.
>> Dude, that was an Iranian pilot who crashed there. Dude,
if those Sue I think two Sue24s or something, two two like MiGs
or Sue 24s or No, they wouldn't be MiGs, would they?
Whatever. Two Iranian fighters got shot down as well. And if
those people ejected, they'd just say that they didn't eject.
Okay, if you're an Iranian pilot who crashed in Kuwait, I do
not think you're going to have a good time. booth on the ground
journalism. >> I don't know why this is the source, but
here we go. >> It even has like no jumper watermark. Are
they doing war reporting over >> Why not? >> We're
all journalists now. There's there no audio. There is audio.
>> Oh, there is audio. Hold on. Start over. >> You're
safe. You're safe.
>> God damn it.
>> You need something to help you?
>> they're friend. >> No problem. You're safe. >> You're
safe. You're safe. Everything good. No problem. >> Thank
you for everything. >> And now never mind. It was Kui Air
defense. I was going to make a joke and now we see why the plane
crashed. DEI pilot again, but it's fine. >> Jesus, that
must have been a very weird and surreal moment for her. Just
she just catapulted out of an exploding airplane. Yeah, you're
right. It's a big diverse reaction. Um, >> but I mean,
all we can do now, listen, nobody knows what's going to happen
>> and we can only just hope that we're on the timeline,
the good timeline where Iraq stabilizes and you know,
>> that one. Yeah, that one. We know how that one ended
or it's still [clears throat] going. But on the correct timeline
where like Persian culture is like one of the oldest and most
prolific, you know, they contributed so much to human culture
and the arts and the sciences and they've just been totally stifled.
Stifened, you know, in the past, I don't know, 40 years or something.
>> Stifer, stipened,
>> been taken over by Islamic extremists.
>> Ciphered
siphoned.
So anyway, >> who was interested in that kind of stuff?
And actually, just, you know, >> this guy is a um I'm trust
me, I'm not going to call somebody who says words wrong. Okay,
I I will make fun of it, but I'm not going to call him.
>> not reflect well on me. >> I think everyone would
love to see a free Iran. I think that would be such a great thing
for the world, but hopefully that's what happens, and we just
don't know at the moment. I mean, it's just like it's just like
a very sad story because um I know that one of Iran's strategies
right now is that they understand that Americans really don't
like losing people in wars like the idea like Americans just
think war is when you go in, you win and no one dies. But obviously
um I think six now Americans have died. Remember Biden's pulled
up Afghanistan. It was 13 people and you never hear the end of
it because it was seen such a massive right. Um Iran is a paper
tiger but a paper tiger can get lucky and I think they are just
hoping that if they kill maybe like a dozen or 20 or two dozen
Americans Trump >> I think the thing that might keep him
in is just like how much of a prize there is for him. Like Iran
is a very very well educated population and they are very very
rich in natural resources. Like it is it is like getting a country
like that back onto your side and away from what they're doing
right now would be such a reward for not just Trump but like
even for the entire region. People talk about Iran as like the
head of what they call the access of resistance, right? But it's
that it's that thing again where resistance to someone in the
west sounds like there's a people that is getting
>> thank you very much for the gifted >> colonized
and they're fighting back with whatever means they can. Um that's
not how Iran sees resistance. Iran sees resistance as any western
presence in the Islamic world as anything that they see as an
affront to their values uh intruding and that also includes anyone
in the Middle East who wants nothing to do with that conflict.
So people in the Middle East and the increasing number of people
in the Middle East who are kind of fed up with this uh old goal
of trying to militarily destroy Israel, right? That that's something
that a lot of people are just kind of fed up with right now.
Even the Lebanese government just today are furious with Hezbollah
for trying to launch the their
By the way, I I also One second. Uh I got to sneeze first.
God, don't you feel a sneeze coming on? Me. Okay. Um, I don't
necessarily think the other powers in the region aren't interested
in that anymore. I think they've accepted that in the current
paradigm with America backing Israel and giving all of their
best American technology to Israel. It's to attack them. So,
I think they are opting for a strategy of biting their time.
I think Israel recognizes this. I don't think Israel considers
them long-term allies.
>> we'd have to see things change really substantially
across that entire region. We liar, dude. Thank you for the sub.
>> For me to think that anyone in that region really thinks
that this is like the it's over, right? I don't think so. I think
they just realize that in the current military paradigm with
America providing unlimited support, there's just nothing you
can do. You're just like right now. >> Well, rockets Israel,
they've actually outlawed as well as military like formerly now.
So, um, but Iran sees resistance as as being against all of that.
You went to >> Oh, hello Accelerate. Thank you for the
gifted sub. One sub away, guys. One sub away from another hour
on the street. >> Not just against Israel or America, but
also against this pacivity in the Middle East, too. Which is
probably why for all of their uh efforts and the amount of money
that they spend on military and foreign endeavors and funding
the Houthis in Yemen or Hzbollah in Lebanon or uh the proxy groups
in Iraq, what have or even Assad's forces, what have they achieved
from it? Like it seems like the only thing that they've ever
been any good at is killing Arabs and other Muslims in in these
countries. They've killed far more than they have Israelis or
Americans. If you look at their the whole time, they helped Assad
stay in power. Assad killed like what three 400,000 of his own
people and just to say just to keep a hold and and they're all
they've all crumbled, right? Like Assad's gone.
>> They fired six rockets. Six. If you asked me like two
years ago, I would have probably said Israel is probably going to
get bogged down and maybe even lose if they fight at the same
time as Hamas. That was usually where the axis and now they're
they're done. And it's also just because people don't really
believe in it anymore or they're struggling to get people to
believe in it because it just hasn't shown any results. So, um,
yeah, I think >> when I was [snorts] in Israel, everyone
was afraid of Hezbollah because the story was they have thousands
of rockets pointed at Israel all ready to go at once. And it
seems like across the board, not just Hezbollah, but also in
in Iran, that the the military might that they that they promised,
that they postured really didn't amount to much on kind of both
sides, isn't it? >> No. uh they were it's again it's just
that whole thing where uh Israel did get very very shown up by
Hezbollah in 2006 but the and their response to that and the
reason they did so much better against them the next time around
and also probably the reason that they did a bad job with October
7th happening was because they took seriously they the whole
one of the things that will probably get found out or confirmed
later with why um Israel was had their guard down on October
7th was because they're they didn't take seriously they did take
us seriously and they did take the access seriously which is
why they focused so much effort on I don't say this to uh political
opponents as well. You have to know the enemy to fight it. So
like it's really Intel just they focus a lot on getting to know
their opponents, finding any cracks in terms of people who might
betray or uh learning they learn about the culture. Um yeah,
they they just they focus so much effort and so much resource
and so much time into making sure that like a 2006 war never
happened again. And I guess it just paid off like um >> and
yeah, I guess it just also seems like the more time goes on there's
you know there's always this pattern with revolutionary dictators
is they always go from like a really compelling leader to a really
bad one. Like you go from Fidel Castro to Ro who no one really
knows or cares that much about or you go from Chairman Mao to
there was a guy between Ma and Dang who came in just after Mau
who didn't last very long at all because he just completely he
just wasn't fit for the position in the slightest. Uh same with
Ayatollah like Rocommeni for as much of a piece of [__]
he was he was very talented and he was very good at what he did
and he had a very compelling aura around him and he was very
charismatic. Uh even the one after him wasn't even like a proper
Ayatollah the one who just died. He was he his process to being
to be an Ayatollah under their rules, you have to pass a whole
bunch of tests and you have to write um I can't remember what
it's called, but you have to write a kind of like thesis or like
a treatise on communicating the the prophets or the god's will
to the masses. He didn't do that. He didn't. Uh you're supposed
to go to the shrine cities and pass a bunch of tests there. He
didn't do a lot of that. He was just sped up there for political
reasons. And I think it's the same thing is that you you just
get a situation where it's easier to sell a vision that doesn't
exist. It was easy to sell the Islamic revolution and this is
the great white hope that's going to defeat Israel and defeat
the West and save Palestine and everything else. Once you get
sort of two or three decades into it, nothing's changed, then
your new leaders just become kind of >> God, I can't do
it. I can't do it. I I want to respond with a joke, but it's
just it's too far. People will stop. >> What are they going
to do with their position in power? They're not really they're
going to be less interested in ideology and probably just more
in self-enrichment. This is what happened with the the CCP in
China from the from Mao up until the 80s and 90s. And it's happened
with Iran as well. A lot of these IGC people are just they're
they're just corrupt. They're just corrupt businessmen. like
they they
goons or they they go to get married in in like western countries
and they drink alcohol on holiday and stuff like that. It's it
becomes very very um unserious is what it is and I really just
feel bad for Palestine at the end of it because because the Iran
has kind of like put themselves up as like the great hope that's
going to rescue them. Meanwhile, I'm pretty sure in the 12- day
war they
>> if this is true, if this is a significant portion of
the IRGC and its leadership, then America like just bribing them
into like accepting maybe that's a reason America's
maybe maybe the fact of the matter might be that America knew
they had like dirt on one of these two guys who were going to
be like next man up and maybe they thought they could control
them. You know what I'm saying? And then those guys get killed
and now they're like, "Well, we don't even have a plan, right?"
Like maybe one of those guys was already kind of sold. Yeah.
Well, hold on. That's the thing is maybe maybe Trump said Trump
said they were killed. The guys we planned for were killed. Yes.
But what does that tell us? That tells us that they didn't expect
those guys to be killed. Right.
This isn't even And they didn't. They weren't doing they didn't
okay the strike from Israel. They didn't do it.
I think there's a chance that they could have had like um like
one of those guys could have been the guy that they thought they
could apply pressure to and get on their side.
Injured or killed about as many Palestinians as they did Israelis.
And um even today I'm hearing from like one of my friends who's
Palestinian uh showing me videos of little buildings in his village
getting having ballistic missiles dropping on >> Um he
said the guys we expected to take over, right? Isn't that what
he said? Hold on, hold on, hold on. But the entire point of saying
this is that you had expectations. You had plans around those
guys taking over,
right? That the thing you expected to happen was a normal succession.
As in you didn't expect there to be some popular uprising. You
didn't expect anything really to to go off or pop off from this.
You expected these were the next guys up. >> I'm just thinking
they deserve higher than this. >> As usual in the Middle
East, it's the Palestinians that end up losing. Somehow that's
always the outcome of of the political games happening.
Somehow I dude I somehow the Palestinians always lose. It's crazy.
It's crazy.
You literally told people to seize the moment after the fact.
>> Um yeah, I mean there is a reality there that without
Iran. >> This is all J. You got to go watch earlier in
the stream. This is basically all out in the open now. Go watch
the stuff from today. Okay.
Israel
Israel did these strikes and the US is along for the ride. There's
no plan on behalf of the US. There's nothing. There's nothing
there. That's why they're desperately approaching the quuades
now, right? Desperately trying to be like, "Hey, maybe you could
go and do like a ground thing." Oh, guys, I'm not going to rule
out ground troops. >> I mean, Israel will be much more,
>> which by the way, I do believe he's ruled out ground
troops. I think he's saying that publicly because he doesn't
he wants other people to join in expecting the US might actually
put people there >> un uh unchained in terms of the in
terms of the things that they can do in the West Bank and in
Gaza. Is that right? >> It's hard to say. I don't I don't
again the question I always ask people and I never really get
a good answer for this. How how is Iran stopping settlers? How
are they stopping anything that's happening in the in the Middle
East? Like the Houthies managed to bankrupt a a port. They bankrupted
a port in Alat in south of Israel. That's about it. They're not
really going to stop like the desire to fight against Hamas.
They never got their ceasefire on the time that scale that they
wanted it on. Um I think it could go both way. So right now unfortunately
the Netanyahu government is very emboldened by the fact that
there's a war. So they blocked aid into Gaza again and the settlers
are taking liberties in the West Bank. I think they murdered
two people today. um that could just get worse in terms of being
unchecked. But then I guess it also depends on like how much
you understand Israelis because I've started to realize a bit
more recently in the last couple years. I feel like what pushes
Israelis to the right is not so much like primarily racism or
supremacy or whatever they say. I think the rightwing wins in
Israel when people are scared. I think if people are that's why
people always talk about like how the Hamas rockets are always
what kind of BB rescues BB in elections because he's always saying
oh you might hate me but I'm the one who keeps you safe. I'm
the security guy. I'm the one who's strong and fights. So with
all that gone, it does make and it makes me think back to what
was the last time when Israel actually moved towards the left
and towards a peace process. It was it was after this the first
emphat and which foreign power with missiles and guns and tanks
or rockets was helping them? No one. The Palestinians did that
by themselves. They fought with stones and knives and you come
out of that in the beginning of the '90s with uh Robin becoming
the prime minister and you have the accords and then you went
into 2000 with the closest Israel and Palestine ever came to
ending the conflict. So it does make me wonder sometimes if these
proxies actually just make things worse.
>> there is elections coming up in Israel. I hold on. Is
there hold on poly market Ubet Yahoo predictions out by the end
of 2026 out by these dates? Really, bro. This is Oh, only $1
in volume. I see. I'm like, bro, hold on. BB Netanyahu. What
will Trump say during this speech? Will he visit NYC? Who will
be the next prime minister of Israel after the next election?
Ah, yes. BB Netanyahu plus 34%. I can't imagine BB ever falls
off again. I I just feel like it's very obvious to me that BB
is going to be winning the next election.
How far does this go back? December. BB was already there. BB
is already the most predicted person. That's crazy. But maybe
this is this factors in a little bit that like
these are the guys who are the coalition
And maybe there's just no no person that's emerged that could
take BB's place within his own party, right? Within his own coalition.
Possibly.
like they they basically give right-wingers in Israel all the
ammunition they need to say no we can't make these these people
if we make peace they'll just get Iranian weapons and come kill
us right so um >> that's actually really interesting I
never thought about it like that but >> um [laughter] prediction
markets I would imagine like you said back when maximus >> if
the prediction markets weren't equal then you could just arbitrage
the fact that it's crypto doesn't mean anything right if the
prediction markets were super far off you could arbitrage between
the two you could you could offset your bets such that you're
making money no matter what so there's basically no reason to
expect that these markets would ever be off significantly unless
they were very low volume, which might have been the case for
this one. I didn't check the volume. No, $1 million in volume.
I would expect them to be pretty much equal to be honest. Yeah.
>> Was prime minister people wanted peace. They wanted
>> I mean also as a I mean I I know I haven't been in Israel
in a while, but from my experience there, it is always the terror
attacks that just make things feel like
you're always in fear. You're always unsafe. >> You give
the government more power because you're scared and you want
them to protect you. And then um I used to hear from my dad when
he used to work in um making gravestones out of marble. He he
used to drive to a lot of places in Palestine and you know like
we don't it's like you shone you know is how they call it in
Israel. But um they would go back and forth like no problem and
there was there were casinos there that sometimes my dad would
go to I remember as a kid. So from what I know it's always been
like terror that makes things worse and then there would be like
a wave of terror and then there's more lockdowns there's more
you know checkpoints all those things. So, I feel like without
somebody like Iran that's um funding it, >> promoting it,
>> I feel like that's only going to get us closer to going
back to like a better
>> I hope so,
>> man. Without Saddam Hussein in the Middle East, we could
just like Israel could just live peacefully. The Palestinians
would be way better off. We get like a leftwing government in
Israel. If we could just get rid of Saddam Hussein, okay, if
we could just get rid of Saddam Hussein, he fired Scud missiles
at Israel. He's like agitating Israel, obviously exporting terrorism
around the Middle East. Obviously, not even terrorism. He's like,
he's just causing instability. He's not like a religious guy.
He's not he's not exporting terrorism. He's just causing instability.
He's like a strongman, insane leader. Okay? So, we need to get
rid of him and then basically we get a leftwing government in
in Israel and and everything's going to be fine. Okay? We got
rid of Saddam. Okay? Now, guys, Assad is a threat to everybody.
He's willing to gas his own people. He's willing to use nerve
agents on his own people. He's a threat to everybody. Israel
cannot really relax while Assad is there. All right? While Assad
is there, Israel cannot relax. So really, we could have a leftwing
government, but it will come in after Assad's dealt with because
that's that guy's crazy. He's plunged that entire uh that entire
country into civil war. That entire country is like a failed
state with a total lunatic in charge of it and he has to be has
to be dealt with. Okay. Now, okay, Assad's gone. All right. Well,
um guys, Iran is the number one exporter of terrorism in the
Middle East. Okay. And Israel will never be safe so long as Iran
is capable of threatening it. So,
and then wait, hold on. We need to go to today. Wait, hold on,
hold on, hold on, hold on. Now, just in case you forgot, now
this is Nap Telly Bennett. And if you missed where he popped
up in the stream just 30 seconds ago, well, he would be the number
two on the polyarket prediction poll for leading Israel after
the next election. Okay, it's the number two guy. All right.
Well, Natali Bennett had to go and say something today which
is very interesting. Turkish threat is emerging. I want to be
very clear. Turkey and Qatar have gained influence in Syria,
are seeking influence elsewhere and everywhere throughout the
region. And from here, I warn
Turkey is the new Iran. I wish I wish I was just like I honestly
wish for your sake that I was just like some ravenous anti-semite
who was super against Israel cuz I hate Jews. I wish for your
sake that you could just dismiss me along these lines. Okay?
But you can't because I'm not. But you can't because I'm not.
Okay? I'm just watching what's happening. I'm just paying attention.
Erdogan is sophisticated, dangerous,
and he seeks to encircle Israel.
And while some senior Israelis
were on Qatar's payroll,
Qatar and Turkey are nourishing
the Islamic Brotherhood monster
that is growing and eventually
uh might become as dangerous as the one created by Iran.
Turkey and Qatar are gaining influence not only in Syria but
also in Gaza
through the front door
and everywhere and trying to create a
>> Turkey is Hamas. Turkey is Guys, is this working on
you again? Turkey is Hamas. Turkey is Hamas. Turkey is Hamas.
Turkey is Hamas.
Um Oh, Maximus, you're like, um I can dismiss cuz NATO. Uh, this
would be if you think that they're going to militarily strike
Turkey or militarily attack Turkey, you are insane.
That is not what anybody's arguing. He's mentioning Turkey here
because he knows Turkey is their next like rival in the
They're not going after them with military hardware while Turkey
is in NATO. They can't do it, right? Turkey are going to have
to be dealt with in different ways, likely economic grounds.
Okay? start hearing about Turkey.
Turkeyy's selling weapons to Russia, so we have to cut Turkey
off. Turkeyy's selling weapons to China, so we have to cut them
off. Turkey is buying oil from Russia. Turkey is buying gas from
Russia. I'm expecting to see things about Turkey violating sanctions
in major ways. Uh Turkey is supporting the Shadow Fleet. Turkeykey's
right. We'll just keep running these things back over and over
and over and over and over and over and over again.
Oh, a new Turkish threat is emerging uh might become as dangerous
as the one created by Iran.
Turkey and Qatar are gaining influence not only in Syria but
also in Gaza
through the front door. Oh, I'm talking about purely economically.
Like Israel did not do did Israel do a lot of um like personal
interventions in Syria was like I know Israel would strike um
they'd strike like runways and stuff occasionally, but I don't
feel like they did like really significant strikes into Syria,
did they? So like it's not it's not about doing military action.
It's about getting narratives going, getting taking economic
action, supporting economic action
>> and everyone and trying to create a new choke rink.
Uh Turkey is trying to flip Saudi Arabia against us and establish
a hostile Sunni access with nuclear >> They hit Damascus.
They do they do do strikes into well I I was talking about under
Assad
Orbeller but they I think they they did some strikes you know
they did some strikes during the
uh right after October 7th because they basically thought Syria
was going to support like Hezbollah right
and but they they did do some strikes while Assad was still in
power but they they were hitting like I think like runways they
were hitting like plane runways in Syria. Yeah.
okay, we're back to >> that's again the good timeline here,
>> you know? I hope so. I think that that actually makes
a lot of sense where it's like
if Iran is no longer funding terrorism and the temperature is
going down so much. I feel like the Israeli public will definitely
move to the I mean, they can they have before,
but right now it's just it's so what they're doing in the West
Bank and BB is just such a ghoul for like send he sends an army
to protect these settlers, right? I mean this is just say state
sanction >> guys. The Israeli people are like totally totally
innocent. They really yearn for a leftwing government. It's just
BB. BB is the only problem guys. BB is the only problem. Wait
is are are you like under dictatorship? No. It's like a parliamentary
coalition. So it's like representative of your population.
No. The population yearns for a leftwing government. Interesting.
I don't know how that works exactly.
Wait. So you have like first pass the post and your country's
like gerrymandered in a way, right? Like your your votes don't
actually go to the people you really support. No, it's like a
directly proportional democracy actually. Oh.
Huh. Okay. Well,
>> violence going on in the West Bank. >> I can't
wait to see what will happen with BB.
>> You're like perfectly represented. You're like perfectly
represented in your democracy. This is exactly what you want
as a country, right? Thank you. Because like you said, he did
always on on fear and because he was like the safe vote for people
when they're afraid. But after October 7th, he lost that. Like
he's no longer that. So I wonder what's going to happen next.
>> He's going to die of cancer. Hopefully >> or in
a jail cell >> or in a jail cell. [laughter] >> Somebody
might rest him in New York. >> He's going to die with the
largest and most celebrated state funeral in the history of your
country. Okay.
The fall of the Iranian regime or sorry at least just this this
overall destabil destabilization of Iran. That guy's getting
a state funeral. That guy's favorables are going to jump up so
insanely in that country.
And honestly, I don't even think like we haven't seen a lot of
polling yet, but I have never I haven't seen a single person
who has come to me and disagreed with me and saying that. They
all basically agree. Even Israeli people agree on this that like,
yeah, we're it's like a thousand-y year BB Reich at this point.
Okay, it's over. >> Who knows? That one I didn't even consider.
Um >> I mean he's not going to jail unfortunately. There's
no way. >> Well, he has cancer, so I think he probably
died of that first, right? He has cancer. People talking about
it. >> Yeah, I saw that like a week ago or two weeks ago.
I >> feel like I've not read that anywhere, but I've only
heard you say it. >> Yeah, that's >> We have elections
this year, October.
>> Well, anyway,
what?
I'm sorry.
That's awesome. That's awesome, dude. That's crazy.
There's no
>> Say what? I can't hear you. >> Sorry. I saw there
was a rumor about the claim that NY has blood cancer lacks >> What
the hell? >> Yeah. Sorry. >> I feel happy. >> I
feel
a human. >> No. We want you dying of cancer. God damn it.
This guy's ruining everything. >> Is he? Is he? Or is he?
So surely if he's ruining everything, I'm I'm If he's ruining
everything, surely he's going to be voted out. Surely the directly
proportional democracy that is Israel will not vote for a coalition
that supports BB Netanyahu, right? There's no possible way. By
the way, I wouldn't be shocked if BB just steps down after this.
Cuz the only thing standing in the way of his party totally dominating,
his coalition totally dominating could possibly be him. I don't
think so. But I wouldn't be shocked if he just went, "Yeah, I'm
out. Yeah, I'm out."
Right? Like like you have to understand he could just step down
and go I'm out and then the legacy of his party because again
I will I will say this again BB is the mirror image of Trump.
He does not give a about his public reputation. He does beyond
what's required for him to do his job. He is he only cares about
the outcomes and how they benefit Israel.
He that's all he cares about.
Like realistically,
if BB Netanyahu cared about Canadians the way he cares about
Israelis, I wouldn't hate the idea of BB Netanyahu as a leader.
Mostly because we don't have a lot of uh ethnic minorities to
oppress. Okay? Like we don't have a lot of we don't have like
a huge population he could just, you know, with. But like he
is he is the best advocate for Israel that's ever existed
by miles. Like if this guy was on your side, you might not hate
him as much. It's that he's not on your side and he's so effective
is the reason you hate him. Okay. Netanyahu every morning in
the
>> I feel happy. [clears throat] >> I feel healthy.
>> I'm a human being.
>> Well, apparently, not apparently, in Congress right
now, there's a bipartisan push to um to vote on what how do you
say to it? >> Normally, they would be voting to grant the
president the authority to go to war, but in this case, it would
be the inverse. They would be basically revoking his ability
to unilaterally do >> Does it look like that will pass?
What's >> not, right? cuz [snorts] there seems to be like
on the right a lot of it seems like not a lot of people are down
with this word in America at all just like univer like three
don't
>> I could see it potentially passing and then him vetoing
it and I don't think that they have the votes >> he can
veto his own rule that's supposed to reanimate >> yeah
it doesn't seem doesn't seem fair but yeah he could we need two/3s
vote to override that which that not
>> that's how America works you can uh the president can
veto and then they the congress has to veto the veto don't >> yeah
exactly the counter veto >> the poor founding fathers they
they had no idea what would happen if one dictator comes into
office >> I don't could have imagined somebody with so
little like I think back then when they made it there was something
about like
people had some level of like honesty and dedication to the system.
Even like the most villainous people I don't think they imagined
could be as bad as Hegith or or Trump or someone like that. Um
>> okay they move on to Donald Trump here. I'm kind of
done with this to be honest with you. Kind of done with it. Kind
of totally done with it. It's very sad.